the federal reserve has been absolutely
under fire when it comes to the
controversy of fed presidents and other
officials that have high ranking
positions
trading sometimes even day trading
various assets that either the fed is
investing in or that they are getting
rich off of while there are many many
americans that are actually not doing so
hot because of the fed's activities we
now have
a semi solution federal reserve is
implementing new rules that will stop
senior officials from trading individual
stocks or bonds you want to work at the
fed you can't trade individual stocks or
bonds you can still invest in index
funds and mutual funds and those types
of assets but you can't actually own or
trade them now the officials will be
restricted primarily to owning mutual
funds which they will have to hold for a
year
and they will need permission to buy or
sell them so again this is a direct
response to the fact that we found out
that multiple fed officials were
literally trading on a frequent basis at
the same time and in some cases buying
and selling the same assets that the fed
was buying and selling they have inside
information now it is not true insider
trading because ultimately it is not
material non-public information from a
corporation but it's almost even more
valuable if you know what the central
bank is going to do before everyone else
and so we've got two quotes here the
first coming from jerome powell he says
these tough new rules raise the bar high
in order to assure the public we serve
that all of our senior officials
maintain a single-minded focus on the
public mission of the federal reserve we
got a second quote from
george selgen who says it's probably a
wise move because the fact is that
distinguishing between genuine insider
trading and just ordinary trades that
look like they might be taking advantage
of insider information is fraught with
problems now with this i actually will
give the federal reserve a lot of credit
here one there was a controversy they
pretty quickly acted in terms of
accepting the resignations i'm not going
to say they pushed anybody out but some
of the people who were embroiled in this
controversy they no longer are at the
federal reserve the second thing they
did is they said we are going to look
take a look at what has occurred and
also what our current policies are and
now just within a couple of weeks they
come out with brand new guidance for
those senior officials new rules that
they must be subjected to including that
they cannot own or trade individual
stocks and bonds that's a pretty good
step but then two is that you have to
actually buy mutual funds you have to
hold it for a year and you need
permission to buy or sell them
so what this looks like to me is the
fact that we actually have a pretty
tough set of rules that is going to be
implemented against the federal
officials the last thing that i will say
is if it's good enough for the fed it
should be good enough for all of the
politicians as well we should take this
exact framework that everyone is
celebrating that now we have appointed
officials who are going to actually not
be allowed to own individual stocks and
bonds that they will have to hold them
for an entire year if it's in a mutual
fund and they need permission to buy and
sell
so should every single politician if
you're a senator or you're a congressman
we don't need you day trading we do not
need you speculating on financial
markets we actually don't even need you
buying and selling individual stocks
that you may actually have the ability
to oversee instead what you should do is
you should be forced to sell all of your
individual stocks you can own indexes or
mutual funds you should have to hold
them for at least one year and you
should have to ask for permission to buy
or sell them the exact same framework
that the federal reserve is implementing
here sounds pretty good we should give a
kudos so congratulations to the federal
reserve for acting not only swiftly but
also with the severity in terms of what
those new rules are going to be but we
should then learn from our mistakes and
we should extrapolate those exact rules
and we should apply them across the
political spectrum every single
congressman and senator should not be
allowed to trade and profit off of
individual stocks and bonds while they
are in office you want to do it before
you're in office no problem you do when
you leave office no problem but while
you serve in office you should not be
allowed to actually do this my guess
though is i'm not going to hold my
breath i do not think that either side
of the aisle is going to agree to this
and as we have seen with many many
pieces of legislation in the past there
is usually this idea of do what i say
not what i do and so ultimately what i
think we're going to see is a lot of
congratulations a lot of applause a lot
of padding on the back federal reserve
great job coming from politicians but
they will not implement this rules for
themselves there is just too much money
the economic and financial incentive is
too high for their ability to trade in
and out of individual stocks and bonds
when
the opposite would simply be owning
mutual funds